All right.
Hello everybody.
Thanks for being here today and welcome to everybody who's watching on the live
stream from our other offices.
Um,
my name's Alex Id and we're really excited today to welcome Alexander Rose to
Google.
I'm Alexandra is the executive director of the long now foundation based right
here in San Francisco.
And some of you may be familiar with their work around the Rosetta Project,
long bets initiative,
some other things,
but surely they're best known for the 10,000 year clock,
uh,
which is a project that Alexander's been working on for the last couple of
decades.
So very excited to have him here to talk about that.
And without further ado,
I'll let him take it away.
Thank you.
Hello.
The,
this project really started with a story and it was,
um,
it was started by a group of people,
who were largely part of the first wave of Silicon Valley people,
uh,
like Stewart brand and Esther Dyson.
And,
uh,
there was the story about these beams at the new college,
Oxford.
And there's these beams that went over the main,
uh,
the main dining hall.
And they were,
when this was college was built,
it was in the 12 hundreds.
It was the new college of,
of the day.
Um,
and it was these huge oak beams.
But 500 years later,
uh,
in the 18 hundreds,
these had become rotted and infested with beetles.
And the problem was you couldn't really just by timber like this in Europe
anymore,
mostly been harvested.
And it wasn't until they spoke to the school forester who said,
oh,
we have the grove of books that you planted.
It turned out that they had the practice of the time was you planted groves to
be harvested hundreds of years later to replace these kind of beams.
Uh,
and so it was this simple story that when Stewart brand who had founded the
whole earth catalog,
uh,
told it to Danny Hillis,
who had been designing some of the fastest supercomputers computers during the
80s with think his company thinking machines that have MIT were Denny realized
that,
you know,
we aren't really thinking like this anymore.
We aren't using these simple leverages over very long periods of time.
And in fact,
by not thinking over these kinds of timescales,
there's some problems that we've taken totally off the table.
So you could imagine,
you know,
climate change is somebody said,
you need to solve it in four years.
You're like,
I can't do that.
But if someone said 400 years,
you can imagine how you might start that project.
And we basically,
by not giving ourselves these kind of timeframes to work on things,
we're basically just taken these,
these types of problems off the table.
And so the idea was to,
uh,
to create a kind of an example of longterm thinking.
And as I mentioned with Danny Hillis,
uh,
was,
was inspired very early on and he had been building a very,
very fast computers and he had this idea of building not the fastest computer,
but actually the slowest computer in the world,
uh,
computer effectively.
That was a clock that was calculating the heavens and the,
and the date over 10,000 years,
this kind of timeframe of human civilization and steward who had been talking
with them about this,
he had started the whole earth catalog as I mentioned.
And you thought,
well,
that's,
that's great if we get people's attention around a longterm thinking,
this kind of monuments scale,
all mechanical thing that,
that gets people talking in a different way about longterm projects.
But what do we do with that?
And he wanted to create a kind of a library of information service that would
last over the same kind of timescale.
And then Brian,
you know,
who,
uh,
was one of the other people that started to be pulled into this conversation,
a musician and artist.
He had this idea of the long now,
which,
uh,
when he,
he had grown up in England and when he first moved to New York in the 70s,
he went to a friend's house and,
uh,
and it was in a really horrible neighborhood.
He was like stepping over homeless people to get into it.
And when he asked if she liked living there,
she said,
yes,
I love it here.
And he realized that the here for her was right between those walls and in New
York.
They also meant when they said now they meant the kind of five minutes that they
were in,
not the larger time that they were in.
And so he kind of started contrasting the long now and the big here with what
people were understanding in New York versus Europe.
Um,
and so we kind of used that term to really stretch it out as to the larger human
moment.
And then this other set of people who,
uh,
as I mentioned earlier,
we're very much part of the early a wave here in silicon valley.
And I think they were really seeing some of the speeding up of culture that
we're definitely now deep,
you know,
kind of hip deepen now,
uh,
back then.
And they,
they were,
they were realizing that there needed to be some kind of counteractive to that.
And that was why they all got together and started the long now foundation.
And I was hired,
uh,
in the,
late nineties,
mid 1997 to start working with Danny Hillis on building this clock.
And I'm going to talk about some of the lessons that we've learned about how to
build things over that can last over a thousand years and a,
some of the lessons we have from antiquity.
And then I'm also going to dive into some of the,
the exact details of the project right now.
And in fact,
some of the pictures that had been taken from the site,
that's where we're building the monument scale version in west Texas.
Uh,
we'll be,
um,
that I just took a few weeks ago were like,
so this idea of 10,000 years,
um,
really came first from this,
uh,
conversation about,
you know,
what is,
what is the right timescale for us to be working in?
And if you want to stretch people's imagination around time,
but if you start working with the kind of galactic timescale,
these kind of billions of years,
the whole human experience becomes totally dwarfed.
So that's not what we wanted.
And even if you start looking at millions of years on this geologic timescale,
it's still a dwarfing experience.
It's very difficult to feel as though you have an effect in it.
But this idea of the last and the next 10,000 years where it's kind of the last
ice age retreated,
we had,
uh,
some of the first,
agriculture and cities,
this,
this was really what we wanted to capture as the human moment.
And I think the most important part of this is,
is not really thinking about ourselves as the kind of end of a 10,000 year story
but more in the middle of at least a 20,000 year story of modern humanity.
And if you start thinking about yourself that way and the projects that you're
working on,
uh,
how would you act differently?
And one of the very first kind of diagrams that we,
that came out of a conversation,
uh,
with Brian Eno and Stewart brand was this one of this kind of layers of human
time,
this pace layering where you have the fastest time and most chaotic elements out
here.
And I would even put some of the,
you know,
modern communication technology is up here on this kind of fashion layer now.
Um,
and then it goes down into commerce and infrastructure and governance,
culture and nature moving the absolute slowest.
And the idea was like,
you know,
how do we know when people are,
are,
are not acting in a,
in a good way around longterm thinking.
And you can imagine,
you know,
when,
when Pacific lumber got bought out by Maxim Corporation and they owned the
largest swats of,
of,
of old growth redwoods and the Pacific northwest,
this was all done in this commercial layer and maximum corporations,
their main goal with all companies was to buy them and sell them for their
assets.
And that's one thing when that's the assets are some buildings and some
machinery.
But in this case,
specific lumber assets were old growth redwoods,
which are down here.
And they basically skipped all this and we're trying to sell off these millions
of dollars of assets in a single generation where they couldn't be replaced.
And then I'll,
you know,
all kind of hell broke loose politically and,
and that,
you know,
they partially,
we're able to sell them off when they partially ended up getting saved and
bought up by,
by other interests.
But it's these kinds of moments where you skip a bunch of these layers that you
realize you're,
you're probably not doing longterm thinking.
Right.
And so
I'm going to talk,
as I mentioned,
uh,
about some of the things that have lasted in antiquity,
some,
some of the reasons why they have lasted.
Um,
but you'll kind of see an a along with that last example that I gave is that for
the most part,
one of the things that we have really realized about,
um,
trying to think about the future in a positive way is that when you're making
decisions that give the future more options,
you're probably doing it right.
You know,
the future will always have more information than we have.
Um,
and we will always have less information in the future,
has so many choices now are often made.
You know,
if you look at let's say something like the,
uh,
the bill of rights where it's 10 things about a sentence and a half each,
they were all very principle based notions that are intended to be reinterpreted
every single generation.
Whereas a modern law is 1200 pages long.
No one's ever actually read it all.
But it's very much intended to have no room for different interpretation by the
future.
Um,
and you can see which ones of those seem to have better sticking power,
um,
the bill of rights or some of these modern laws that,
that really don't even,
uh,
a lot of people don't even know what's in all of them.
Um,
so I'm gonna move over to the kind of mechanical side of what I do.
My background is in industrial design and as we have been designing this clock,
I've been collecting various examples of,
of ways that things have lasted.
And one of the most amazing examples is this one,
which is the,
and ticket their device,
which was,
uh,
a very small piece of a kind of corroded bronze that was found off the coast of
Antarctica,
Thera Greece.
And for a long time people realize it was special that it had gearing and,
and these markings,
but it wasn't until they started doing x-rays and,
uh,
other types of scans and then we're able to reconstruct it that they realize
there's actually an astronomical clock.
It was,
it set back the date of,
of a lot of gearing and astronomical knowledge,
uh,
by almost 1500 years.
Once it was really understood what it was,
it's pretty amazing in that sense.
And no one's ever found anything quite like it.
But the really interesting thing to me is that,
um,
because it was mechanical,
if this was let's say an electronic clock that had been on the sea floor for
2000 years,
um,
it would not have been,
uh,
there's,
it would be no way to reconstruct it.
So you know,
why is,
why is the clock that we're building electronic or mechanical instead of
electronic?
It's because it gets,
it has this kind of self documenting feature even with,
uh,
you know,
something is corroded as some of those pieces I showed you,
they were still able to figure it out.
So you want to be able to design something not only to work,
uh,
in,
you know,
it's kind of designed operation state,
but also in it's failing operation state so that people can reconstruct it.
Another interesting thing that happens is this idea of sacrifice.
And we,
we,
we often see this in nature was something like a lizard that can lose its tail
and still go on to live.
But in antiquity,
we also see it where something like the Pyramids,
uh,
you know,
they,
the tombs were lost.
The outer casing stones were eventually stripped off.
But if the intent of the,
of the original builders was to keep pyramids around for 5,000 years there that
would have this,
this would've worked.
And when people took off of these outer outer parts and stole the value from the
inside,
they kind of felt as though they'd extracted all the value from this.
Um,
and for probably the builders they did.
But if we imagine that the ability,
his intent was just to keep pyramids around for 5,000 years,
then that,
that would have been success.
And you also see this in something like the Taj Mahal where,
uh,
the whole insides of it work in crusted with all kinds of jewels.
And when it was finally sacked by the British for the time,
they spent a long time prying all these jewels out of the walls and we still
have this amazing architectural artifact that wasn't destroyed because they felt
as though they had extracted the value with that they felt was just the gems.
The other strategy is to make something remote.
And this,
this kind of has two elements to it.
One is that there's also a kind of a,
a mystery that people are getting intrigued by when things are remote.
This is a picture of the seed vault in Svalbard.
Uh,
I was there a few winters ago.
this is what it looks like when you're flying into the airport there.
That's the,
the airstrip and it's,
it's extremely remote.
It's the most northern,
most permanently uninhabited place on the planet.
Uh,
and the seed vault is meant to store a copy of crop seeds from seed banks from
around the world,
uh,
which it does.
And what was amazing to me after traveling all the way,
there was this signing into this guest book.
I was signing him behind banky moon and Jimmy Carter.
And in people,
there's something about these remote sites that,
that people really find a really compelling and kind of becomes part of this
myth in our case,
hopefully of longterm thinking that we want to promote.
The other interesting tactic is to just take a really long time building
something.
Um,
the,
the cathedrals of Europe are,
uh,
are definitely in this van.
So this is the cathedral at Cologne.
It was,
uh,
it took 600 years to build a start in the 12 hundreds and finished in the,
in the 18 hundreds,
and it's actually still kind of under construction.
Um,
but it helps pass this,
uh,
this point.
And,
and,
and another cathedral that's a great example is La Familia.
And,
uh,
in Barcelona,
the Sagrada Familia,
I'm sorry.
Um,
and it,
you know,
it was,
it's now on its fourth or fifth architect,
most famous,
one being Goudy.
It's 125 years into building.
It probably has another hundred and 25 years ago,
but it's already a UNESCO world heritage site,
even though it's a construction site.
Uh,
so it's,
it's kind of passed this very critical time that all of these things do.
And we didn't even see it here in San Francisco of look kind of one generation
after some things built as the most dangerous time for anything to last because
it's kind of your parents thing.
It's not cool anymore.
Uh,
but once it passes that generation and then it's kind of this antique and then
people want to keep it.
And so grad familiar went through this very much.
It was an unworked on for a whole generation until somebody else picked it back
up again.
Okay.
And
in Japan we see another strategy,
which is that they're just really good at maintaining things.
So,
so these are two of the oldest continuously standing,
uh,
wooden structures in the world.
Um,
and they've just been meticulously maintained in a very wet environment.
Uh,
but they're kept the roof on.
They've replaced things as they've gotten rotten.
Um,
but there are over 1400 years old and they're made of wood.
So even some of the most materials can last for thousands of years if,
uh,
if done right.
In fact,
there's a even more ephemeral material,
uh,
temple site,
that Shinto shrine that's,
that's close to this one where they rebuild the site every 20 years in an exact
replica and they've been doing that for over 1600 years and that's just that and
would so it's a,
it's another way of this kind of renewal of a,
of a design.
It also keeps once a generation people actually teach the master of teaching and
apprentice and going on a generation after generation.
And um,
another interesting problem that I've noticed is,
is that,
you know,
as,
as you look around the world,
most things that are designed to last for several thousand years are being put
underground.
But one of the big problems that happens there is that,
uh,
that people always think they can keep the water out.
Uh,
what I've learned is that you can divert water.
You can't stop water.
Um,
so you can choose where water wants to go.
Ah,
this was the last picture they let me take before going into the Mormon
genealogical archives outside of Salt Lake City.
Um,
I did find some pictures from inside there.
Amazingly,
but the Mormon,
uh,
archives with the built in this bunker,
um,
and the goal was to keep the water out.
And,
uh,
the all of those,
all of those drawers that were in that last slide,
the whole,
all the bottom ones,
they don't keep filled because it's already flooded like five times in the 40
years it's been around.
Um,
and the,
uh,
they,
they basically can't keep the water out.
So all they do is they've dug trenches under the vault doors to let the water
through the site.
And this is actually a picture of the pumps at the,
that they had to install at the seed vault in Svalbard.
And,
uh,
the other underground sites like the nuclear waste sites,
um,
are also already having these problems even before nuclear wastes,
it gets put in them.
So it's a,
it's,
it's an interesting thing that many of these sites have chosen to be
underground,
but they have a,
unfortunately thought that they can stop the water.
And the last one that I'll mention is this idea of ideology.
This is a picture before and after pictures of the Buddha's at Balmy on in
Afghanistan.
This is a person to give you an idea of scale there.
They're massive.
But the Taliban spent,
uh,
weeks,
dynamiting those Buddhas out of that cliff face,
um,
for an ideology as kind of innocuous as Buddhism.
That's pretty impressive.
And,
and you know,
lung now does have an audiologist ideology of longterm thinking.
Um,
and I think this is one of the most,
the largest dangers and trying to create something that's gonna last for a very
long time is,
uh,
you never know who's going to choose to take that on as a,
as an enemy.
Uh,
as I mentioned before,
I get into the clock.
Stewart brand had talked about,
uh,
this idea of a very longterm library and,
um,
and Alex mentioned our Rosetta Project,
so I just did just want to touch on it.
Uh,
early on in,
in this,
we realized we needed something that could also record culture over the kind of
timescale that we're talking about.
Not just inspire people to think long term.
And we looked at this,
you know,
the Rosetta stone itself,
which had a two languages and three different scripts.
And it was kind of the key to deciphering hieroglyphics.
But that even with that,
it took 50 years of,
of effort to decode hieroglyphics.
That's also another good example of how pretty much how bad really a
pictographic languages are.
And we often think like,
oh,
if you're going to want to last something,
if you want something to last for a really long time,
just draw pictures and everyone to understand.
But it turns out pictures are super ladened with culture.
They're the most difficult things to understand.
It's way easier to decode something like an alphabet that's phonetic like ours.
And so we thought we wanted to make a modern version of this.
And so what we did,
we spent about a decade collecting,
uh,
parallel languages and 10 different elements of languages.
The parallel text,
uh,
a map of where it's found a basic description of it and then instead of etching
it into stone,
we could take these thousands of pages and use a galley.
My on being the same technology that's used for micro circuits and just write
the actual text into silicon and then plate on top of that,
uh,
metals that can last for a long time,
like nickel or Rhodium.
And so we put a 13 and a half thousand pages of language documentation on this
disk,
uh,
one of which was launched on the European Space Agency's Rosetta mission.
If you remember,
just a few years ago,
uh,
the spacecraft landed on this comment.
And so it's now our piece of,
uh,
language documentation that's going to continue to orbit the sun in perpetuity.
So the clock,
this is the project that,
uh,
I have been working on for 21 plus years now.
We started with a prototype that we finished it in 1999,
uh,
that one's now at the Science Museum in London.
And then in 2005,
Jeff Bezos,
founder of Amazon came on to fund the full scale version that we're,
that we're now building.
And,
uh,
so I'm going to talk about just kind of a couple of the design problems that
we've solved in working on the clock.
And,
uh,
this is a picture of the sun at noon throughout the course of the year.
This is what's called the Anna Lemma.
And this is a,
it's a summer solstice is the top when you're still at the bottom,
the equinox.
And the reason I'm showing this is that the clock that we wanted to build,
we wanted to have a way for it to not drift.
It's timing over the course of 10,000 years.
So we wanted a way to synchronize it and candidly to the sun on a nice sunny
day.
But we also wanted it to be able to keep time between those sunny days with a
pendulum that's keeping what's called absolute time.
So the difference between solar time and absolute time is this kind of plus or
minus 15 minute difference here.
And then it varies throughout the course of the year.
So normally if you wanted to have a pendulum keeping absolute time synchronizing
to the son,
all you'd have to do is make it a cam.
That kind of corrects for this one and dilemma.
But the problem is if you're trying to build a 10,000 year clock,
the earth is also processing on its poles every 26,000 years and it's slowing.
It's rotational rate by about a second century.
So all of that had to go into a shape that is,
that turns around once per year,
but as read over the course of over 10,000 years to give us that plus or minus
15 minutes difference as it evolves for 10,000 years.
So this is kind of a,
this one shape is that equation of time as it changes.
Uh,
we left,
we've made this a 12,000 year camps.
You had a thousand years in the beginning of a thousand years in the end to make
a new camp.
The,
uh,
the site that we're building at now,
is in west Texas.
The very first site that we actually purchased a site in eastern Nevada.
Uh,
that was in the great basin national park that's covered in some of the oldest
trees in the world.
Bristle cones,
which was an amazing sight,
but also became very difficult.
Permitting was,
and,
uh,
Jeff Bezos,
when he came on with the funding for this project,
uh,
he was also buying some of these ranch properties in west Texas for his blue
origin launch facility.
And,
uh,
we found this amazing site that's karst limestone,
something that we can carve and underground.
Um,
it's also very close to Carlsbad caverns.
We knew that it could support underground structures and that case for 60
million years.
Uh,
and so in our case,
we just needed the 10,000 and in 2010 we started
the underground work.
So we were going to,
the goal was to build,
uh,
an underground structure that started,
oh,
sorry,
that started looking like this kind of rough old mining entrance.
And then,
uh,
as you move through it by the end and seeing the whole clock,
it would then look like this,
uh,
very,
very manmade.
Uh,
totally,
uh,
smooth hewn project.
And as a,
as you saw before,
you know,
there's,
there's one type of,
of underground work that's the kind of the earliest way,
which is using explosives to um,
to work.
And that's,
that makes it very rough surfaces.
So that worked for the beginning of our project,
but then we have this design where we wanted to have this kind of like forced
perspective,
spiral staircase,
underground space where we're working basically carving very smooth surfaces
underground.
Uh,
and we found in Carrara,
Italy,
they do this but just to do,
to work effectively in the positive,
just to cut big blocks of,
of stone out from under the ground.
And so we borrowed one of the s these nine foot diamond chainsaws from them and
we built a 36,000 pound diamond chain,
saw a robot
that has been working well.
Now it's done now it spent two years cutting plate by plate,
uh,
out from underground.
And then once you break out the plates between those cuts,
yeah,
we were left with what we wanted,
which was both that kind of a hall space.
And,
um,
350 feet vertical feet of diamond cut stairs.
And that just finished up about a year ago.
Okay.
And that's before the railing got installed.
It's gonna have a nervous time.
It's a 500 vertical foot a whole.
So,
uh,
working there as a little bit tense.
The um,
the other parts of the clock and we're not done with the clock.
Um,
but a lot of it is,
is getting very close to being done.
Um,
I'm going to show you a little bit about the chime generator and the power
system,
the power system,
uh,
and I'll be able to show you some images.
In fact of the power system which we just installed on site in West Texas.
The uh,
the chime generator that we built,
uh,
this was the very first prototype of it where it can ring a series of 10 bells
in a different sequence each day for 10,000 years.
So when I mentioned that Danny wanted to build effectively the slowest computer
in the world,
this is kind of one of those,
it's a,
it can do 10 factorial,
which if you do that math,
it does come out about 70,000 days short of a once per day for the entire 10,000
years.
But the bell,
the bell is only ring on the days that people are there to wind the clock.
So we assume there'll be a few miss days.
Um,
but then we needed to scale that design up to this kind of thing that's in the
spiral staircase that,
uh,
that people would experience on this kind of architectural scale.
And that's what we've been building,
uh,
largely out of parts that are machined up in Seattle.
But then this is our shop,
uh,
right up here in San Rafael.
Each one of these,
uh,
module layers rings a bell and there'll be bells hung between them and there's
10 of them and it,
it'll be 80 feet tall.
And that's the next thing that we installed at the site.
It's a 60,000 pounds a bell ringing device that we're going to be lowering in in
the next few months.
And the power system was an interesting problem with the roof.
With the first prototype of the clock that we built,
we realized that there wasn't really a way for people to interact with the clock
and we,
um,
without someone being able to kind of own the moment that they have with it.
It didn't really have the effect that we were after.
And so we realized that we did want people to wind the clock,
but we also didn't want it to lose time when people weren't there to wind it.
And so what we ended up with was as a kind of a two part system where the,
the clock is the part of the clock that keeps the time is wound by the
temperature difference from day tonight,
there's at the very top of this mountain,
there's a tank of air that expands when it gets warm and a metal bellows expands
and we get just enough energy basically to keep the pendulum ticking and to know
where the now point is.
But to show you that now point and for all the chimes to ring that use all the
energy for those bells.
Uh,
we,
uh,
we require that people wind it.
So when people come,
they wind the clock all the way up in the rewarded with the bells ringing in the
all the different dials updating.
And so once you get into this kind of level of human interaction with big
mechanical things,
um,
we had to build some of these very large gears and also really where we're doing
effectively experience design.
We're kind of designing a ride,
uh,
that are,
we're trying to change the way people think from the beginning to the end of
that ride.
Uh,
and work with a very large machine that's effectively storing 15,000 pounds of
weight that can fall over a hundred feet.
And one of the,
the most difficult problems that we had early on in this project was bearings.
Uh,
if you're trying to make,
uh,
something that rolls over something else that lasts for thousands of years out
of metal,
it's very,
very difficult.
Uh,
and when I started on this project,
the,
um,
I found the right solution and it was a bearing was developed for satellites and
does these ceramic bearings that are kind of engineered diamond hard ceramics
and they don't rust.
They don't weld to themselves,
they don't need lubrication.
They're designed to work in the space,
but they cost about $60,000 each 22 years ago.
Um,
but now they're in fidget spinners and roller blades and the cost $5.
So,
um,
it was one of those very happy accidents of technology that uh,
that allows us to basically every single moving part in this clock is using
ceramic bearings of some kind,
either with metal races for some of the very large ones or ceramic on ceramic
bearings.
And,
uh,
this is the power system as it was being tested,
assembled,
uh,
at the shop.
And this is us putting it in literally just a few weeks ago at the site.
Yes.
So for each one of these builds,
we have to build a temporary work deck,
which we're working on there.
It's 150 foot fall from where we're working.
Otherwise.
But even so we're all working on tethers and everything comes from the surface,
partially assemble
and in some cases is assemble with thermo fitting with towards,
that's the temporary deck getting installed for the next level.
And that's the 15,000 pound weight [inaudible]
that store is energy for the clock over,
uh,
over time.
And the,
um,
basically it can,
you can even run for over a century,
uh,
without being wound by people just just from that itself.
And this is our amazing crew of,
of engineers who've been working on this.
Um,
so I'm just going to show you some of these last few slides of that.
I,
that I took,
um,
well doing these last installs.
Um,
just to give you an idea of the scale.
the next thing as I mentioned is going to be the chime generator and then the
dials and then the parts that go at the top that uh,
do the self winding and the solar synchronizing.
Um,
we were just there.
Okay.
The very last thing that we did was hook up the winder and uh,
so these guys are winding the clock for the first time.
And that,
that big kind of thing.
In the middle there is a rack gear that's being wound up with the weight on it
and you can tell it moves very,
very slowly.
It would take probably,
uh,
a whole day winding to bring it up to the top.
And just a couple other local things that I'll mention since you guys are here
in San Francisco.
Um,
some of you may have been to Fort Mason.
Uh,
our headquarters are,
uh,
are right there next to green's restaurant.
We actually have a bar and cafe called the interval,
um,
that we operate downstairs of our office.
And we also do a lecture series.
They're on long term thinking and then Stewart brand hosts a series mostly at SF
jazz on longterm thinking.
Um,
last night at the interval we had Brian Behlendorf,
one of the early founders of open source movement and Linux and a on Monday at
SF jazz we have one Bennett,
uh,
talking about longterm info structure,
using blockchain technology for a file sharing and
without,
I can take questions.
Can you talk a bit about maintainability?
There's all these like really large gears that you machine.
Then the ceramic ball bearings.
Like how do you expect people in 5,000 years to be able to replace parts if they
need to or anything like?
Well,
um,
the tolerances that we operate on are actually very,
very sloppy con in its comparison to modern machining techniques.
We are using modern machining techniques,
but um,
but actually you could cast these same parts out of bronze and still do it,
which would be kind of 5,000 years ago.
Technology.
Um,
we have made,
um,
we have made as much of the clock as possible disassemblable and carry outable.
Um,
but we also are trying to balance that against people stealing parts of it over
time.
Um,
so you can,
um,
the parts that you need to get to,
you can,
without taking the entire clock apart,
like to replace a bearing or something like that,
you could replace any of the bearings that we are putting in the clock with
stainless steel bearings or some future material that is maybe better than even
than ceramics as well.
Our goal was that we,
you know,
we tested all of the cycles to the number that they need to do and beyond,
uh,
in making the clock.
But that's not to say that something won't happen that causes that maintenance
to be needed,
but our hope is that,
uh,
at least kind of very large scale maintenance does not have to happen.
Yeah.
Hi.
I'm just want to make sure you can hear me.
Uh,
so two questions.
First is when do you expect the construction on the clock to be completely
finished and open to the public?
And then the second,
um,
I don't know if you necessarily answered this,
but you know,
why a clock,
if you want to inspire people to think long term,
you know,
you brought up the concept of library.
You were certainly,
um,
you know,
quick to bring up like Silverado Familia and some of the other like,
why is it that it was a clock that was finally decided upon?
Um,
yeah,
so I'll take the last one first.
The,
um,
I mean I think it really could have been anything.
And I think there's also the question and you know,
why of monuments scale clock,
right.
And,
um,
the,
the goal was to,
to create a kind of a,
you know,
in a way,
a theatrical experience that changes the way people think about time.
And if we're going to,
um,
if we're going to do that on this human scale,
I mean,
you could pick a,
there's all kinds of ways to build a 10,000 year clock.
You could plant forests every,
you know,
kind of pie shape of forest every hundred years or something like that.
So there's a,
there's many ways to do it.
But,
um,
we were looking for something that would create,
that would hold an image in people's minds that they would want to travel to,
or even if they never traveled to,
they would still kind of be able to hold a reference in their lives as a,
as a,
as a object that was made by people that was designed to last for that long.
Um,
and since it's about time clock just seems to make sense in that,
in that scale.
Um,
yeah.
So I think,
um,
there's,
there's all kinds of ways to do it.
This is one of the ways that we chose.
We also,
as I mentioned,
we have many other projects.
Um,
we also have a project on,
you know,
betting on longterm things of scientific and social consequence.
Um,
we have that there was that a project and lectures,
but I think,
you know,
if you're,
if you were,
we could have just released a white paper on longterm thinking,
but,
um,
you know,
how effective is that in terms of actually making new stories and new myths,
a new cultural memes,
probably not very effective.
Um,
so we wanted something that people would actually tell stories about.
And,
um,
we've been lucky that there's already been even,
we're not done with the clock.
We had,
you know,
Neal Stephenson wrote a book called Nfm,
uh,
who's,
it was in New York Times bestselling science fiction book that was about a world
with 10,000 year clocks in it.
So,
you know,
we're starting to get the right new stories told.
Uh,
hopefully there will be more than you had another question.
Oh,
when it'll be done.
Yeah.
Um,
we don't have an end date.
We've never worked towards an end date or with an end date.
We're very to have a patron that allows that.
Um,
and um,
the goal has always been to just do it right.
And,
uh,
but I would say,
you know,
we're,
as you can see,
we're vastly more far along than we were two decades ago.
And,
um,
we're now at the point where working pretty quickly is required just kind of
from an efficiency standpoint where ever we have everybody that's designed it
still on the team,
they all go there for the installation and we don't want to lose those people,
uh,
to other projects as we,
as we finish this.
So we're trying to work pretty,
uh,
pretty effectively.
So it's feeling like years,
not decades at this point.
Yes.
We will see it will be open to the public,
but yes.
Not yet.
No.
If we could do one question from the door,
either online questions,
uh,
someone actually asked about the novel Nfm that you mentioned.
Um,
and,
uh,
specifically as to the events described in the novel,
in turn inspire any changes in the 10,000 year clock
work that's ongoing?
Um,
that's an interesting question.
I think,
I mean,
we refer to that novel and so just to catch everybody up,
I won't without giving any spoilers.
It was,
uh,
it was,
a world not this world.
Um,
but I'm kind of in a parallel universe that I'm the only academic people in the
world lived in these kind of cathedral,
like things that had these either a century clock or a thousand year clock or a
10,000 year clock.
And,
uh,
the rest of the entire world was basically kind of like mall culture.
Um,
and so all of the academic thinking in longterm thinking happened,
uh,
in these,
in these cathedrals.
Um,
and we're,
and so it was kind of like monks,
but they weren't a religion.
They were a religion of longterm thinking in a way.
And,
um,
so,
uh,
I think we have often referred to the book in the sense of like,
who is going to be that?
The people who,
um,
help either maintain or are they kind of docents have this experience,
uh,
or just protect it.
Um,
and so that I think has been informed by that a little bit.
Yeah.
Uh,
thank you.
do you have any thoughts about what Google can do to influence London thinking?
Uh,
yeah.
What can Google do?
I mean,
I think one of the problems that we started working on in one of the reasons
that Rosetta project came up,
um,
and we did it in this extremely analog method of something that you can put
under a microscope and read rather than on floppy disks or hard disks or
whatever,
uh,
was because we realized we're were,
we're effectively archiving the world's culture at this point,
uh,
as born digital information,
um,
or retroactively scanning it in.
Um,
and you know,
a thousand years ago we wrote things down on rocks and you can still read the
rocks.
And a hundred years ago we wrote things down on books.
And you can still read the books.
20 years ago we wrote things down with some of the early databases,
which are all totally lost,
right?
And,
um,
we have definitely have some of some great advantages.
Now two things are much more connected and things are in a way more
interoperable because of the Internet,
but we are not archiving things the way that,
uh,
that can be necessarily read in thousands of years.
And,
um,
so as I think that Google is in a a unique position obviously of having so much
data,
so much,
so much writing material.
I mean,
if,
if the modern William Shakespeare was writing now,
would you be able to read that content 500 years from now is an interesting kind
of question to ask yourself.
And uh,
you know,
the,
the design principle that we use on the clock is if we burrowed into the
mountain and we found the clock already there,
what do we wish we had found?
And so I might ask you to think about the ways that information is being created
and stored,
that if you found it a thousand years from now,
what do you wish you had done to make sure that that data was saved?
Uh,
which alternate with the Dory?
Um,
someone asks about the sky map at the Hoover dam.
Are you familiar with that area?
And you have any,
any comments?
Add A,
yeah,
so there's a,
there's a very interesting site,
um,
that is,
uh,
very poorly documented.
And if you have ever visited the Hoover dam,
you probably have visited it and not known it,
but as you,
um,
as you come down onto the damage now I guess you can walk on,
but you can't drive vehicles on.
They have a new overpass.
Um,
there's a inlaid floor that was done by an artist named last name of Hansen,
I believe.
Uh,
and it's,
and then there's just too beautiful statues next to it.
And what he did was he used the procession of the equinoxes that I mentioned
that are Kim references to,
um,
to make an image of the,
of the night sky.
And the major planets and stars.
Um,
the day that the Hoover dam was,
was,
uh,
commissioned effectively.
And so setting in in time,
the date of when the Hoover dam was built in this floor,
a terrazzo floor that has absolutely,
it's super beautiful and it's super well thought out and super well done.
Um,
unfortunately that whole site is run by the Bureau of land reclamation,
which is not the most future thinking a site or one that cares as much about
this.
So they have almost no information about it.
I was able to talk them out of sending me the blueprints for it and uh,
I scan those and put them up on the Internet archive and did a whole blog piece
on the lung.
Now blog,
if you're for people who are interested,
I think it's probably most documentation that that site has.
Um,
and it's,
uh,
it's a really cool one and if you're ever at the Hoover Dam,
you can impress your friends by pointing it out.
So it's two questions.
So they probably,
you know,
first one you probably answered like say the cloak is ready on the next day.
Something like the rapture acquirers,
I neighbor,
every human being disappears.
You expect the clock to work actually 10,000 years with no one actually looking
at it.
Um,
the second actually has to do with the,
they're like the Japanese approach or the temple approach under the Japanese
one.
Like there's two ways to do it.
Like the statical thing that is meant to work or someone called an evolutionary
thing that you will depend on some kind of mission that actually holds itself to
advance.
Right?
Because in his 5,000 years,
they every kind of language reference to English the United States.
Yeah.
Or human like gold,
you're disappears.
Uh,
are we able to get some kind of other culture to understand what they see is
like,
is it self documentary enough over?
Because if you have like this kind of,
um,
I dunno,
mission that actually can keep going on regeneration to generation.
Which one do you think is more reliable?
Both wrists,
right?
Um,
yeah,
I mean,
I think the probably the largest risks to the clock is people,
but the reason we're building it is for people.
So,
you know,
we designed it very much for people and to work with people.
But,
um,
you know,
we,
we did,
we have done it.
We have made best efforts to make sure that everything will work for 10,000
years all by itself.
The dials wouldn't update,
but it would still,
no one now is,
and if someone showed up at the end of that 10,000 years,
they could wind it and get there.
Um,
the question of,
um,
if the,
uh,
sorry,
the last question was about,
um,
kind of approaches that you can take like this problem of Oh,
the incremental approach.
Yeah.
So,
uh,
again,
the goal here was to get,
make something that people would tell stories about.
And I think,
um,
you know,
people do tell stories about some of these other things like the,
um,
the,
the Shinto shrine at Esa.
Um,
and certainly hope there's whole belief systems that,
um,
that that's central to.
And so that's a totally reasonable one.
Um,
this was just kind of the one that we chose to give a try.
Uh,
and so the,
the documentation part of it,
we,
that Rosetta disk that I mentioned,
um,
we did put all the plans of the clock on that desk,
uh,
and have continued to update them as some of the new versions of that desk has
come out and,
uh,
gives us a way to document over very long periods of time.
Was there anybody,
let me take one more.
Sure.
Um,
so there's,
uh,
there's a bunch of questions online about sort of the,
you know,
the longterm resistance of the clock.
The Earth is in motion,
complex system,
all that stuff.
Um,
so maybe just a couple of those.
someone asked,
uh,
what happen the event of an earthquake
if it's resistant.
And there's another question about,
um,
how much change can be tolerated in the temperature difference that actually
powers the clock.
Uh,
good questions.
Yeah,
so I'm the earthquake thing.
We,
you know,
we're building in West Texas,
which is,
it's not the most stable tectonic place on the earth.
Something like Australia probably would be.
Um,
but it's pretty stable.
And,
um,
we started with a geologic report that basically said,
that we're up to a 6.0 may happen.
It's a one in 10,000 chance that a 6.0 will happen in 10,000 over the course of
10,000 years.
So we,
uh,
we went with 6.0 as our Richter scale design and even did some simulations of
that big weight that was hanging to see if it would swing and weird ways and
rack into things,
um,
and uh,
and made a few modifications to,
to deal with those kinds of waves that might come through the site.
Because of that.
Um,
as I mentioned,
we're in,
we're very close to Carlsbad caverns and those caverns are built in the exact
site or built where they were.
They were formed in the same limestone and have lasted between two and 60
million years.
So the underground space is pretty darn,
um,
I think resilient on the kind of timescale that we're talking about.
And uh,
what was the last one?
A temperature difference.
How much could be different?
Could be tolerated.
Um,
yeah.
So the temperature,
the thing that,
that synchronizes the clock to the sun as well as the thing that,
uh,
pulls energy is a differential engine.
It is not a absolute engine.
Um,
and so,
uh,
there's,
the air system is kind of,
it's the,
the seals on it,
our ceramic and,
uh,
the Piston is graphite.
And so it's not like sealed with rubber.
Uh,
we didn't think there's any kind of seals like that that would last anyway,
but they basically let a little bit of error by,
so,
um,
they're always finding a kind of the design was to find a about a week long
equilibrium of what average temperature was to then have a tank that that's
getting heated by the sun to give you a difference.
And so even some of the places like Antarctica,
um,
have,
uh,
or some of the hottest deserts in the world,
they still have huge differences between day and night temperature,
even though they're at their absolutes are much more extreme than we are now.
So should work.
We'll see.
Thank you everybody.
[inaudible].